it was new year's eve december 31 192.80
commodus started the day as roman
emperor but he fell to an assassination
plot orchestrated by his mistress marcia
first she tried poisoning him but
because he was already drunk commodus
quickly fell ill and vomited the toxin
before it could take effect then marcia
resorted to less subtle methods as
she simply sent a wrestler into the
emperor's chambers to strangle him
commodus was dead and so with him was
the nerva antonia dynasty as he had no
children of his own and never adopted
any heirs
the question now was who would become
the new emperor this would not be an
easy thing to answer
in fact the collapse of the nerve
antenna dynasty plunged the roman empire
into the most turbulent period of its
history so far in 193 a.d
five men would vie for power and in one
way or another each one of them
would lay claim to the roman throne
eventually after betrayals
conspiracies and assassinations only one
would emerge
triumphant ready to forge his own
dynasty following the chaos known
as the year of the five emperors
[Music]
[Music]
by the time commodus had perished he had
made sworn enemies out of the roman
senate
therefore they immediately went to work
undoing many of the changes he had
brought on and
even had him declared a public enemy of
rome they realized that news of his
demise would create
chaos so they kept his death a secret
until they already had someone lined up
to follow him as emperor that someone
was pertinax according to the astoria
augusta and cassius dio
pertinax was born in alba pompeia in 126
a.d
he did not come from a noble family as
his father helvious successors was
a freedman meaning a former slave who
had gained his freedom pertinax received
only a modest education and
originally intended to become a teacher
but found that military life was more to
his liking with the help of a family
friend who was a former consul he
obtained a position
as a cohort prefect in syria as the
years went by pertinence steadily rose
through the ranks especially
after distinguish himself in the parsian
war during the
reigns of antonius pius and max aurelius
pertinex spent
decades in the military moving from
syria to britain then
moishe to dacia he became a trusted aide
of claudia's pompeonus one of the
most important commanders under marcus
aurelius and for his efforts he was
granted several governorships and a
consulship before being
finally assigned to the senate and when
commodus was dead
two men who had been involved in his
assassination electus and latest
concluded that pertinax had the rank the
experience and the popularity
to become the new emperor when he was
told of this pertinax first sent a
companion to see the body of the former
emperor
indeed the reign of commodores had made
a lot of men paranoid and
they feared that something like this
could be a test that might end in their
execution
after he was convinced of the truth
pertinax went to the praetorian barracks
to get them on his side
basically he told them that commodus
died of natural causes and promised them
a money gift called a donate of him
so they would support his ascension to
the throne finally he went to the senate
where he stated his case but also
offered to step down if someone younger
and less feeble than him was more
suitable for the job apparently it was
this modesty and practicality that
convinced the senate
that pertinax was the best candidate so
on january 1st 193
a.d he was crowned the new roman emperor
the people of rome seemed pleased at
this development as they
chanted the name pertinax and slung
insults commodus then angry mob
also demanded the former emperor's body
so they could drag it through the
streets and tear it to pieces but
as it had already been interred they had
to settle for smashing up the statues of
commodus by all accounts pertinax tried
to be a good ruler cassius dio said that
he showed humaneness and
integrity and careful consideration for
the public welfare he also wanted a more
democratic reign so he refused fancy
complicated titles
and instead styled himself as chief of
the senate a very old position from
before the days of the empire
unsurprisingly pertinex continued
reversing many of the policies
instituted by commodus and
was more in line with marcus aurelius
and of course
this got him killed it won't surprise
you to learn that pertinax did not have
a long reign after all we're going to go
through five of them in a single year
his biggest mistake was angering the
praetorian guard
technically they were meant to be an
elite unit of rome's greatest soldiers
who acted as bodyguards and intelligence
officers for the emperor in reality
though
they were one of the empire's most
corrupt institutions and as the de facto
armed forces inside the city of rome
they knew that their support was
important for an emperor and regularly
bargains their position into obtaining
more money
power and privileges it was not uncommon
for the guard to turn against an emperor
once they felt that it was time for a
change or
if they believed that a newcomer would
be better suited to their interests
soon enough the praetorian guard were
about to commit the most
heinous act of their 300-year existence
because commodus didn't really care
about ruling rome effectively and
because he already had plenty of other
enemies to worry about
he made sure to always be on the good
side of the praetorian guard
by granting them a lot of concessions
pertinax on the other hand
was a strict and disciplined military
man and intended to reform the guard by
curtailing a lot of its privileges a
plot against him was almost inevitable
in fact he survived the first one
uncovering a conspiracy to usurp the
throne
and replace him with a console named
falco but afterwards around 200 to 300
soldiers of the praetorian guard simply
stormed the palace they struck pertinex
down
cut off his head and placed it on a
spear thus ending his reign
after 87 days
[Music]
as word spread throughout rome of what
the praetorian guard did to pertinax
most city officials
ran tide in their homes one of them
however immediately saw the opportunity
placed in front of him realized that the
throne was up for grabs
that man was a preconsole named didious
giulianis he made his way to the
praetorian barracks but wasn't allowed
inside the camp and
was shocked to discover that somebody
else had the same idea as him the
prefect of rome
titus flavius sulpicianus as not only
the prefect but also pertinax's
father-in-law
sulpichianus originally went to the camp
to try and smooth over the situation
with the praetorians
this was before pertinax had been
assassinated but once he learned of the
emperor's demise he thought he might as
well make a play for the throne
so he offered the same people who had
just murdered his son-in-law a money
gift if they would support his ascension
as the new emperor julianis heard this
and even though he had not been allowed
inside the camp he shouted at the
soldiers that he would make them a
better offer now the praetorian guard
understood the situation in front of
them so
they proceeded to start a bidding war
between the two officials but
we'll let cassius dio tell the story
since he was actually a senator in rome
at the time
then ensued a most disgraceful business
and one
unworthy of rome four just as if it had
been in some market or auction room
both the city and its entire empire were
auctioned off
the sellers were the ones who had slain
their emperor and the would-be buyers
were
and julianas who vied to outbid each
other one from the inside
the other from the outside they
gradually raised their bids up to twenty
thousand sirs to seize per soldier
some of the soldiers would carry word to
giuliani's sulpichianus offers so much
how much more do you make it and to
subjiannis in turn
giulianis promises so much how much do
you raise him
in the end didius julianas offer 25 000
seas per soldier which roughly means
around
65 000 to 75 000 in modern currency he
also argued that if superkianis were to
become
emperor he might attempt to avenge
pertinax's death
this offer was enough to sway the
praetorian guard who decided to make
didious julianas the
new emperor of rome later that same
night giulianis rode through the streets
of rome with
the guard by his side weapons out and
standards held high as they
made their way to the forum and then to
the senate house this was an
intimidation tactic and it sent a clear
message
the praetorian guard supported didier's
giulianis and anyone who opposed him
would have to deal with them going back
to dio's account who again was a senator
at the time
he said there was a genuine fear among
his peers julianis had called upon them
to come to the senate house and
confirm his emperorship but they were
worried that those who had been friends
of pertinex or
enemies of julianas would simply be put
to death indeed cassius dio
was both he had been granted a
praitorship by pertinax and
had also accused giulianis of several
offenses but there was also concern that
those who skipped the meeting
would simply be hunted down in their
homes so with a lot of trepidation the
senators made their way to the meeting
place
genuinely not knowing if they would be
leaving the senate alive that night but
again
let's hear from the first-hand account
of the man who was there so when bath
and dinner were over we pushed our way
through the soldiers entered the senate
house
and heard him deliver a speech that was
quite worthy of him in the course of
which he said
i see that you need a ruler and i myself
am best fitted
of any to rule you i should mention all
the advantages i can offer
if you were not already familiar with
them and had not already had experience
of me
consequently i have not even asked to be
attended here by
many soldiers but have come to you alone
in order that you may ratify what has
been given to me
by them i am here alone is what he said
though he had actually surrounded the
entire senate house outside with heavily
armed troops and
a large number of soldiers in the
chamber itself moreover he reminded us
of
our knowledge of the kind of man he was
and consequence of which
we both feared and hated him with no
other choice the senate confirmed
didious giulianis as the emperor of rome
and
he went to the palace that night where
he had a feast and celebrated with games
and music while the corpse of his
predecessor still lay on the palace
floor the next day a riot broke out as
the people of rome firmly rejected
julianas as a legitimate emperor however
they stood no chance against the
praetorian guard and many were slain
in the clashes that followed
by buying the loyalty of the praetorian
guards giulianis might have had a firm
grip on rome but the roman empire was
much bigger than just one city and the
guard might have been feared by senators
and common citizens but
what about an actual army what about
rome's greatest generals who commanded
the loyalty of their soldiers far more
than
whomever was sitting in the roman palace
would they simply roll over and accept
julianas as their new leader
especially after a blatant and shameful
ascension that was decried by both
politicians and
plebeians alike well no of course not
but this was called the year of the five
emperors after all we've had two so far
so
three more were coming but unlike
pertinax and julianas who
followed each other in sequence the
other three made a play for the throne
at the same time
they were persennius niagara september
severus and claudius albinus they shared
similar circumstances all three were
successful respected roman generals who
were
popular with the men under their command
at the time all of them were serving as
governors
severus in pannonia alveonus and britain
and pesennius and syria
once word reached them of what didius
julianas had done their men all
recognized them
as the new emperor and agreed to march
on rome on their behalf
there are three groups that a would-be
roman leader has to contend with the
army the senate
and the common people with two out of
three their ascension is pretty much a
done deal
julianas showed us that you can have
even just one of them then get the
second one by force and
not care about the third but these three
generals all had their own armies and
it's a pretty safe bet that the senate
and the people of rome
would have preferred any of them over
didier's giulianis
so which one would win in the end
gaius persennius niger was born circa
135 a.d in a small town
called aquanum in provincial italy he
came from more modest means compared to
his rivals and
was part of an equestrian family we
don't know much about his early career
but his military record allowed him to
rise above his station eventually
becoming the first member of his family
to become a senator under commodus
after several governorships and
consulships throughout the empire
massenius ended up in syria
in 191 a.d by all accounts he was well
liked by the people in syria and by the
senators back in rome in terms of
military support pretty much the entire
middle eastern section of the empire was
behind him
syria egypt jerusalem arabia and
cappadocia
if the romans had it their way it would
seem that they would probably want
bessenius to be their new emperor
according to dio
it was his name that the citizens
shouted and praised whenever giulianis
was out in public
unfortunately for them pesennius was the
furthest one of all stationed at the
eastern edge of the roman empire the
closest one was septimius severus who
was
in pannonia this was a roman province
right next to italy
born in africa in 145 a.d in the ancient
port city of leptis magna
severus was the son of a roman mother
and a carthaginian father he first
traveled to rome when he was 18 and
began working his way up through the
ranks of the roman public office which
was also referred to as the cursus
honorum this culminated in 191 a.d with
the governorship of upper pannonia
also under commodus dio described
severus as
the shrewdest of the four men fighting
for the throne as soon as he heard of
the death of pertinax he
made preparations to go to rome and
become the new emperor he had the
support of
most of the soldiers in central and
eastern europe while those in britain
gaul and the iberian
peninsula were behind claudius albinus
speaking of whom
our last contender was born circa 147
a.d possibly in the
african city of hadrimutum located in
modern day tunisia we say
possibly because the main source of
albanese's early life is history
augusta which is notoriously unreliable
like the other two albinus was
made a governor by commodus back to
septimius severus because he was
stationed close to italy he was the
first to make his way towards rome a
calculating man severus realized that
even if he did not take the throne he
would immediately have two powerful
rivals to contend with neither of the
other two were likely to give out their
claim just because didious giulianis was
no longer emperor therefore he
sought out a pact with albinus and he
sent a letter where
severus agreed to recognize him as
caesar if he were to remain in britain
we're not sure exactly if this meant
that the two would rule together or if
severus offered to
appoint the other governor as his heir
but this was good enough for albanus who
stayed put at least for now as far as
giulianis was concerned he offered
little resistance to septimius severus
first he tried to send prefects and
ambassadors to him either to delay his
advance or
to persuade his men to abandon him
however the opposite happened and
more of them ended up siding with
severus the general then captured ravana
and its fleet without
a fight as most of the populace he
encountered preferred him over julianis
according to dio
there was one battle between the
praetorians and severus forces but the
praetorians were absolutely crushed and
did nothing worthy of their name and of
their promise the historian
thinks that this was because the
praetorians had become too complacent or
had learned to live delicately as he put
it they were fine when they threatened
old senators or went up against citizens
armed with rocks but got demolished by
an
actual battle-hardened army other
sources say the battle was not even
necessary as the praetorians abandoned
giuliana's old mass as
severus advanced in a desperate attempt
julianis went to the senate and asked
them to talk to severus so that the two
of them could rule together
of course it was far too late for such
offers once severus sent word to rome
that he would spare the praetorians as
long as they surrendered the ones who
assassinated pertinax his fate was
sealed the guards arrested giulianis and
turned him over to the senate
he was then sentenced to death septimius
severus was proclaimed the new emperor
and pertinax was deified didious
giulianis was executed on the 1st of
june 193
a.d after just 66 days as emperor he is
barely remembered today but what he did
was almost
impressive in a way as he managed to
become as hated by the romans if not
more so
as notorious emperors like caligula or
nero
and he did it in just two months
septimius severus was the new ruler of
the roman empire but he still had a few
threats to deal with
for starters the praetorians clearly
they could not be trusted he might have
promised to spare their lives but that
did not mean he couldn't punish them he
summoned them all and
after chastising them for their actions
against pertinex he confiscated their
arms and horses and
banished them all from rome now onto the
more serious threat pesennius who
clearly had no intention
of giving up his claim to the throne
fortunately for severus he
also had the weaker army and according
to dio the weaker mind he was getting
too cocky and
more puffed up than ever as the
historian put it and hearing all this
stuff about the people chanting his name
in the streets of rome and
his own soldiers referring to him as the
new alexander
went to his head he was certain of
victory but was about to have a very
rude awakening
persennius set up headquarters in
byzantium a city
deeply loyal to him from there he
marched his army and met severus in
battle for
the first time that year at the city of
sizexus
not only was he defeated but one of his
most trusted generals emilianus was
slain
not surprisingly severus kept the
pressure on after his victory
and laid siege on byzantium forcing him
to retreat further east into nicaea
another battle took place there in
december
and it resulted in another triumph for
septimius severus bessenia says imperial
dreams were starting to shatter not only
did he suffer multiple defeats but he
was beginning to lose support as
some provinces like egypt and arabia
switched their allegiances to severus
one final push was all it would take to
finally break him it didn't happen until
193
but it did occur the following year at
isis during one last major battle
between the two sides
vesenius not only lost again but was
captured by the enemy during his retreat
he was beheaded
and then severus sent his head on a pole
to byzantium which was still under siege
in an effort to get them to finally
abandon their loyalty to him
it actually took two more years before
byzantium fell but once that happened
severus's position was secured
there was just one problem left claudius
arbenius the last remaining pretender to
the throne
he was proclaimed emperor at the same
time as severus but the two of them
forged a tenuous alliance with albinus
accepting the title
of caesar and ruling over most western
parts of the empire while
severus was dealing with besenius and
byzantium but albinus
was fully expecting to one day become
emperor should severus die before him
but the latter had no intention of
allowing this to happen and probably
never did
severus had two sons and he wanted them
to follow him as emperor not albinus
first severus tried using trickery and
sent assassins to albanus under the
guise of messengers
they failed however and now there was no
choice but open combat between them
albinus began mobilizing his troops in
britain and proclaimed himself sole
emperor while
severus did the same except that he
named his eldest son as his co-emperor
in late 196 a.d albanus and his forces
crossed into gaul
and he fought severus on february 19 197
a.d at the battle
of lugdun modern-day leon in france this
would have been a massive conflict for
the time as
dio mentions that each side had 150 000
soldiers
the tide turned several times as neither
one dominated the field of battle but
ultimately septimius severus was
triumphant once more
albanus retreated to lugdenham but once
the war was lost he killed himself
severus took his head and sent it to
rome making it clear that he finally
reigned supreme
[Music]
with all the other contenders out of the
way there was nobody left to challenge
the authority of septimius severus
it might have technically lasted over
four years but the year of five emperors
was finally over and the severan dynasty
could begin
first came a show of dominance as
severus looked to punish all of those
who showed support to his enemies
particularly in the eastern parts of the
empire which had aligned themselves with
pesennius
there were executions there were exiles
and there was a lot of confiscation of
property
after all severus had grand ambitions of
conquest and those don't come
cheap his first military campaign took
place in 197 a.d against parthia
like many roman emperors before him he
was moderately successful and captured
some territory but in the end despite
two long sieges he failed to conquer the
fortified city of hatra
just like trajan had failed almost a
century prior
his other main military campaign was in
britain in 208 a.d
where he intended to conquer caledonia
which roughly corresponds to scotland
nowadays
his initial foray was successful even
though it came with heavy casualties as
the caledonians refused to engage in
open combat and
kept utilizing guerrilla warfare by 210
a.d the enemy had been defeated and left
no choice but to sue for peace but the
terms were so one-sided that they
rebelled just a few months later severus
prepared for
a second incursion this one was the
intent of wiping out the caledonians
completely
his orders were let no one escape sheer
destruction
no one our hands not even the babe in
the womb of the mother
if it be male let it nevertheless not
escape sheer destruction
he did not live to see his orders
carried out though severus was already
sick and stricken with gout and
arthritis he fell ill during the
campaign and feeling it was the end he
retreated to eboricum or
york as we call it today and died on the
4th of february 211 a.d
before his demise severus had made his
younger son guerta
a co-emperor as well with hopes that he
would reign alongside his older brother
this would not come to pass however as
his eldest would go on to become one of
the cruelest tyrants to
ever sit on the roman throne but we will
explore that story
another day when we take a look at the
reign of caracalla
so i really hope you found that video
interesting if you did please do hit
that thumbs up button below don't forget
to subscribe
and thank you for watching